ce dimanche des chinois éco citoyens ont
investi saint rémy les chevreuse ou la
plupart venaient pour la première fois
les membres de l'association des jeunes
chinois de france sont arrivés de toute
la région pour ramasser les déchets
abandonnés et puis l'espace racines
jusqu'à la réserve naturelle près du
château de vosgiens aidé d'une famille
soirée -
tous munis de gants et de sacs
plastiques colorés pour le tri sélectif
ya de tout il ya du vert il ya des beaux
coups de canettes beaucoup de plastique
beaucoup de deux barquettes un peu comme
ça là où
de restauration rapide et georgette
donc on trouve beaucoup de déchet lors
des routes qui mènent dans la nature
afin d'endiguer ce fléau la ville
s'inscrit dans un programme lancé par le
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse programme appelé nettoyage
de printemps l'autre méthode pour faire
évoluer les comportements
sensibiliser les plus jeunes ainsi les
groupes scolaires de saint rémy les
chevreuse ont adopté des arbres
fruitiers
chaque école aujourd'hui travaillent sur
la découverte donc de l'environnement à
travers la plantation de ces arbres
fruitiers sur la préservation aussi de
tous pliés environnement espaces verts
jardins
parfois les enfants sont déjà éduqué au
respect de la nature comme sept
participants de 10 ans très impliqué ce
dimanche
franchement les déchets ya des poubelles
un peu partout on peut les jeter donc
quel message toi tu aimerais faire
passer aujourd'hui que certains
on a pas besoin d jeter partout parce
que on a juste à faire quelques pas pour
les jeter dans une poubelle extrêmement
pour la nature
chaque année sur la commune 12 mètres
cubes de déchets sont ramassés puis mené
à la déchetterie prochaines dates de
ramassage le 6 avril à chevreuse et
magny les hameaux